- All right, everybody.
Let's wrap up this hour with
something simply charming
from the pages of social media.
This is what I'm liking.
(rock music)
Most people say dogs
are man's best friend,
but for one Los Angeles man,
his best friend is a wild squirrel
that he named Richard, 'cause why not?
And Richard's now living
quite the lavish life
as you'll notice.
In fact, he's got his very own house
complete with a fountain,
yard, white picket fence,
and a working television inside.
So he's beating some humans right now.
Richard's become a social media sensation
with 250,000 followers on Instagram
and we have his caretaker on the line now
watching on NBC 4 Los Angeles.
Everybody say hi to Derrick.
(crowd cheering)
What's up Derrick?
- Hey Kelly.
- Oh my God.
I want one of those shirts.
That's amazing.
- Listen,
I'm gonna send you one.
- So tell us how you came
like Richard came into your life.
How did this happen?
- So about a year and a half ago, Richard,
he was on my fence, okay.
And I looked at him and I was like, hmm.
I looked at him, I said,
"Hey, are you hungry?"
And he stopped, he looked at
me and I was like, "All right,
lemme go get you some food.
I'll be right back."
I went and grabbed him some peanuts
and he was in that same exact
that spot four minutes later.
That's how long it took me.
And from there we just
started this relationship.
And then, you know, he came
around every single day
and I was like I might as
well build you a house.
It only sounds right.
We're basically family at this point.
(Kelly laughs)
- I love this so much.
So you also decorate the house
to go with different seasons, right?
- Absolutely.
So, you know, just like
anybody else's house.
- [Kelly] I love it.
- When the seasons change,
the same things should happen
with Richard's house, it only made sense.
So we have fall, we have,
you know, Halloween.
I made it real spooky.
You know, Christmas is
coming up, so it's only right
that we deck the halls
with lots of jolly, okay.
Michaels, the craft store,
even sent some things.
- Oh my gosh, Derrick, I love you so much.
I love Richard even more.
That's so cool.
Like what you created is so fun, so cute.
Thank you so much for sharing with us
and making us all smile.
I'm liking your post now.
(crowd cheering)
And that's not all.
Our season long partner
Pilot Pen, makers of G2
the go-to pen of The Kelly Clarkson Show
want to honor truly unstoppable
people just like you.
So they're gonna give you $1,000.
How's that sound?
(crowd cheering)
- Hey, listen, I ain't never
gonna turn down no money.
Thank you so much.
(Kelly laughing)
- Oh my God.
I love you so much, Derrick.
Have such a great day.
A big thank you to all our guests today,
Chloe Grace Moretz, Matt
Rogers, Martin Schwartz,
Davine Kelsey, P1 Harmony,
Ky Reed, Tommy Clark
and all our friends at WBAL TV 11.
Y'all have a great day
and if it's not, try and change it.